الى الزميل المعتز ابي الله حسن ليطلعنا
على الاوضاع في مدينه شانلي اورفا وفي
الولايات عموما التي ما زالت حتى هذه
اللحظه تحاول التعاطي مع عمليات الانقاذ
بعد ان تركها اغلب سكانها لكن ربما نقترب
اكثر معك المعتز بالله حسن ما الذي يجري
ما الذي تابعته منذ وصوله اليوم الى هذه
المدينه مركز الزلزال كهرمان مرعش
عبد السلام ساصف لك ما شاهدته اخر شيء قبل
هذه المقابله كنت قادما الى هذه النقطه
لاننا هنا الاتصالات ضعيفه جدا في كهرمان
مراش هناك مشكله حقيقيه في الاتصالات في
مدينه كهرمان مراش ربما هذه النقطه
الاتصالات فيها قد تبدو افضل ولكن في
العموم هناك مشكله جئت قبل قليل من موقعي
احد المباني المعدمه كان عامل الجرافه
يعمل
بدقه من اجل ازاله الاتربه والحجاره
المنهاره ومن ثم تقف الجرافه لياتي عمال
الانقاذ ويضربوا الاضواء الى الداخل ويسال
هل هناك احد هذه العمليه هي تمشي ببطء
شديد لانه ورغم اننا في ربما في مسائل
اليوم الرابع من هذا الزلزال الا ان الامل
لم ينقطع بعد بالوصول الى ناجين تحت
علميا قد يكون هذا الامر صعبا ولكن
الانسان لا يستطيع الا ان يعمل من اجل
الوصول الى من هم تحت الالقاد هذا هو حاله
رجال الانقاذ الذين يعملون في مكان اخر
كان هناك انتشار للعديد من الجثث
وهذه الجثث يتم نقلها عبر سيارات
الجنازه الى نقاط محدده حيث تتم محاوله
التعرف على هذه الجثث ومن ثم توضع في
قوائم ليعلن عنها لاحقا بالارقام الرسميه
السلطات التركيه تقول انها لا تعلن الا عن
الارقام التي يتم التاكد منها الان الذي
تشاهدته
واضحا بالنسبه الي ان هناك مساعدات غذائيه
جيده في المنطقه هناك الجميع يحاول تقديم
المساعدات الغذائيه هناك حاجه للدفء هناك
حاجه للماوى هذه ربما من اكثر
التي شاهدتها هنا في هذه المنطقه لان عدد
السكان الذين اصبحوا دون منازلهم هو عدد
كبير جدا اكثر من الف مبنى في مدينه
كهرمان مراش
هدمت وهناك مئات القتلى وبالتالي العائلات
التي نجت او العائلات او الناجون من هذه
هذا الزلزال دعك من من فقدوا اقاربهم فقط
هم ايضا فقدوا الماوى وهذا امر صعب جدا
نقطه اخرى مهمه جدا هي موضوع الخدمات
اليوم هناك مشاكل بالبنيه التحتيه وواضحه
جدا في المناطق التي شهدت الزلزال ربما
الان لان الكارثه جديده هي ما زالت ربما
لم تتضح بعد ولكن هناك مرضى بحاجه الى
ادويه السلطات اصدرت قرارا بان المرضى
يستطيعون اخذ دوائهم دون وصفه طبيه لمره
واحده من الصيدليات وذلك
ريثما يتم تنظيم هذا الامر هناك جهد واضح
السلطات من اجل
تخفيف حده هذه الازمه الكبيره جدا
والكارثه الكبيره جدا ولكن مع ذلك هناك
وضع انساني واضح على الارض
هو يتطلب الكثير من المساعده